we go into another striking method but
it's
uh menuchi gether and gosh
men men
gucci strike to the front
so it's just it means a strike to the
front and get a and guys
uh you all know that it's a strike to
the knee
because you're striking to a person
everything is going forward so be
careful
in it while i'm like you know we get
confused sometimes
talking about use the hips use the hips
we'll actually use the pelvis
the rotation the rope
the rotation
this way is rarely used
it's more like a tip
this looks over exaggerated but
tip
most people use far too much movement
really than the body requires
the better you get the higher grade you
get the the less you'll
use a lot of body movement
so as before menuchi get engaged
the left hand both together
look past the arm keep this elbow
reasonably in open the front foot
as it drops
and the hip comes forward
goes to the other side not everybody
does it but i have this open
and then i'll turn the hips to bring
this
through step forward
again do not step
round step around if you miss their knee
if they jumped out of the way
you've opened your kidneys up to them
being able to
ski you
[Music]
so
hey hey
[Music]
okay so we're starting to build the
menuchi
series the next one we manage you shiro
ski
don't worry